it's gamescom we get our first look at
four guys season 2
some more ratchet and clank ps5 gameplay
and some more details about destiny 2
beyond light
i'm lucy and these are the biggest news
stories from gamescom's opening night
live
season one of fall guys the feel good
hit game of the summer hasn't even
finished yet
but developer media tonic has given us a
look at what we can expect
from season two there are gonna be brand
new medieval themed mini games and
costumes there'll be a giant castle for
tail tag and a new block pushing mini
game
where you have to climb over castle
walls but most importantly
they'll be brand new costumes including
a witch wizard
dragon knight and a viking some of the
same game modes will be returning but
with brand new maps and obstacles
you've gone around a month until season
two begins which is very good for me
because i still haven't had my first
season one win yet
[Music]
we got an extended look at ratchet and
client gameplay on ps5
and a little hint as to when the game
will actually be coming out
the gameplay demo showcase during
opening night live was an extended
version of the one featured during the
ps5 reveal event
early in the demo ratchet inadvertently
shoots nefarious dimensionator
causing dimensional rifts to appear
everywhere
ratchet can use his new rift tether to
grapple glowing yellow rifts
and pull himself into them instantly
teleporting to other parts of the area
according to developer insomniac the ps5
horsepower allows the team to fill the
game world with density
and life players also won't experience
any load screens
at all during game now ratchet incline
grifter part doesn't have
a confirmed release date but insomniac
confirmed that the game will be arriving
within the ps5's launch window although
sony hasn't actually revealed a release
date or price with the ps5 yet but
hopefully that'll be coming sometime
soon
please be soon because i've
pre-registered to pre-order a console
and i don't know when it's coming out or
how much it's going to be
but i do know that i'm excited to play
ratchet clank on it so
we got another look at destiny 2's
upcoming expansion beyond light
and the brand new stasis powers that are
gonna come with it
while beyond light is gonna be shaking
up the game world by removing some
planetary destinations and introducing
some new ones
arguably the biggest change for the
expansion is the new
stasis ability now for warlocks there's
the shade bringer which looks like it
fires a lot of long range freezing bolts
at enemies
hunters get the revenant class which
seems geared at controlling the
battlefield with freezing fields and
storms
and finally there's the behemoth for
titans which is all about sending ice
rippling through the ground to freeze
enemies and then using titan's big melee
hits to shatter them
we also get the sense that you'll use
stasis crystals to instantly create
defensive structures
like walls which can help you close the
gap on enemies to deal punishing blows
now stasis is the power of the darkness
the nebulous big bad enemies that
destiny guardians have been worrying
about
since the original game's first day in
the current season of destiny 2 the
darkness has
finally arrived but it's not attacking
it's handing out
gifts stasis seems to be one of those
gifts and its appearance should have
a huge impact on the story and yes i am
super stoked that we caught a glimpse of
dragon age
four but come on bioware give us a
proper trailer
please feed me from the rest of our
coverage on gamescom
2020 make sure to check back here
youtube.com
gamespot or check out the site
gamespot.com on tomorrow's generation
next we will be talking about gamescom
obviously but we'll also be talking
about pre-registering to pre-order the
ps5
as well as which monitors and tvs you
should be looking at if you want to
upgrade your setup for the next
generation
see you then
[Music]
you